breaking news meine damen und herren
denn nach exklusiven informationen die
aus der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz an uns
durchgedrungen sind ist deutschland eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ein großes stück
näher gekommen bei uns im studio ist
paul ronzheimer paul welche
informationen hast du bekommen ja mein
kollege ralf schuler und ich haben
recherchiert aus dieser runde was olaf
scholz zu allgemeine impfpflicht gesagt
hat und ich zitiere einmal den
zukünftigen kanzler er hat gesagt er ist
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht und er
werde diesem vorhaben als abgeordneter
im bundestag zustimmen wenn es dort eine
abstimmung gibt das ist das erste mal
dass sich der bald kanzler olaf scholz
so direkt für eine impfpflicht für alle
ausspricht zuvor das wissen wir ja gab
es bereits den beschluss für eine
impfpflicht für pfleger für
krankenhausangestellte und so weiter
aber das ist eine allgemeine impfpflicht
kommen könnte das war bislang unklar
auch wenn einige äußerungen in die
richtung gezeigt haben unter anderem
schon von markus söder den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten und anderen in der
union aber die spd war damit rücksicht
insbesondere auch die fdp bislang
zögerlich wenn ich mich festlegen würde
müsste dann würde ich sagen die
impfpflicht die wird kommen was heißt
das denn dann genau also wann wird sie
kommen zu wann also wann müssen alle
geimpft sein das ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch völlig unklar das ist
eine debatte die dort gerade läuft aber
dass sich der bald kanzler oder schaut
so klar dafür ausspricht dann kann man
davon ausgehen dass im nächsten jahr so
machen es andere länder wie österreich
zum beispiel die alle eine allgemeine
impfpflicht bereits beschlossen haben
dort soll ab februar eine impfpflicht
gelten in der tat das ist ja auch immer
wieder gesagt worden dass eine
impfpflicht jetzt keinen schnellen
effekt habe um die welle zu brechen aber
ein ganz klares indiz der zukünftige
kanzler mit seiner
richtlinienkompetenz ja sagt dass er
seinem gewissen folgend als
bundestagsabgeordneter für eine
impfpflicht stimmen werde das ist ein
völlig eindeutiges signal und thomas ist
eine 180 km 180 grad wende des künftigen
kanzlers dennoch am 17 september hat er
gesagt ich finde es wäre falsch wenn
jetzt eine debatte beginnt über im
pflichten oder ähnliches siebter
september vor der wahl nicht mal drei
monate her 180 grad wende von olaf
scholz jetzt sagt er er würde für eine
impfpflicht stimmt und wird sicher
spannend was die fdp dazu sagt die
künftige ampel regierung einer der
partner in dieser ampel regierung die
sich bisher dezidiert dagegen
ausgesprochen hat ist denn bisher ist ja
alles genau abgestimmt worden keiner ist
da alleine vorgeprescht mit einer
meinung die möglicherweise völlig
konträr zu den partnern wäre ist da im
hintergrund ein abstimmungsprozess
womöglich auch gelaufen ich gehe fest
davon aus dass olaf scholz diese meinung
gegenüber der fdp bereits vertreten hat
er ist jemand der so was genau
koordiniert der nichts überraschendes
macht der nicht einfach christian
lindner postiert so schädlich ist
zumindest ein und noch etwas spricht
dafür rafael buschmann der künftige
justizminister hat sich gestern in einem
interview mit rnd ähnlich geäußert und
hat gesagt man könne eine abstimmung im
bundestag über die allgemeine
impfpflicht machen er hat nicht gesagt
er selbst würde dafür stimmen aber er
hat gesagt so eine abstimmung im
bundestag wäre möglich wir haben denn
die ministerpräsidenten darauf reagiert
was hat er da gehört es gab zum einen
zustimmung bei der cdu insbesondere da
gibt es ja ministerpräsidenten die das
schon seit tagen teilweise seit wochen
fordern insbesondere markus söder allen
voran der bayerische ministerpräsident
aber auch andere michael müller der noch
bürgermeister von berlin der hat
angemerkt naja wie sollen wir das ganze
dann kontrollieren was bedeutet dass
dann wie soll denn festgestellt werden
wer geimpft ist und wer nicht und das
hat dann wieder eine erneute debatte
entfacht dort und es gab noch einen
zweiten wichtigen punkte in olaf scholz
angesprochen hat der für alle zuschauer
wirklich wichtig ist es wurde erstmals
darüber gesprochen wie lange die impf
zertifikate gültig sein werden da ging
es um die frage wann läuft eine impfung
ab also wenn ich zwei impfungen habe wie
lange bin ich dann zweig also geimpfter
und da hat olaf scholz gesagt es kann
nicht sein dass jemand der zwei
impfungen hat 20 jahre lang zweig sei
als auch diese debatte ist eröffnet das
haben wir auch in den vergangenen wochen
erlebt michael kretschmer zum beispiel
hat gesagt nach sechs monaten sei das
eigentlich vorbei helge braun hat das in
dem interview mit meinem kollegen
teilweise schon einmal gesagt dass
tastan vorbei sein könnte also auch da
gab es hinweise und auch da scheint sich
jetzt der neue oder der designierte
kanzler oder scholz festzulegen und wird
auch dort möglicherweise eine neue
regelung ein fest ich jetzt heute
überrascht weil in den letzten wochen
hat man ja nicht so besonders viel von
olaf scholz gehört und jetzt kommt er
gleich mit solchen zwei knaller aussagen
hier um die ecke mich hat die klarheit
von olaf scholz überrascht dass er so
klar sagt er würde dafür stimmen das ist
ja eine aussage und das bedeutet für
mich wenn er das als designierter
kanzler sagt dann hat er das gefühl die
mehrheit in seiner zukünftigen koalition
die will die impfpflicht und er wird sie
auch durchsetzen und das ist das erste
zeichen dass diese impfpflicht kommen
wird das betrifft also ein drittel der
deutschen bevölkerung für 15 millionen
die im moment noch nicht geimpft sind
welche die zahl richtig im kopf habe das
wird eine gewaltige logistische
herausforderung ja dann auch noch mal
sagen das wird eine gewaltige
logistische herausforderung sein wir
haben am anfang in dieser internen
debatte erlebt wie über die impfung
gesprochen wurde da geht es darum dass
olaf scholz gesagt hat 30 millionen
impfungen bis ende des jahres dass das
was die virologen gesagt haben die
müssten seien deswegen brauche er den
krisenstaat deswegen brauche er diesen
general über den alle gesprochen haben
und dann gab es ja den hinweis von
markus söder dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten der gesagt hat
moment mal wo es eigentlich ihr
gesundheitsminister aber man muss eines
klar sagen das sind alles
nebenkriegsschauplätze die nachricht des
tages olaf scholz will eine impfpflicht
für alle das ist eine kehrtwende eine
180 grad wende bei der spd ja und wie er
darauf jetzt gekommen ist dass er das
eben gerade heute verkündet das hast du
ja nachher auch die gelegenheit zu ihnen
noch mal zu fragen denn er wird ja heute
nachmittag direkt im anschluss an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hierher
kommen um eben mit dir das interview zu
führen was werden da die wichtigsten
punkte seien neben der impfpflicht
natürlich die impfpflicht wird das
zentrale thema natürlich sein und die
frage warum er jetzt eine art meinung
vertritt als noch vor drei monaten ich
habe gerade das zitat angesprochen
natürlich wie geht es mit krone weiter
kommt wirklich kein lockdown wir wissen
ja momentan wird darüber diskutiert
haben wir gerade in der sendung
besprochen dass diskotheken und clubs
geschlossen werden die cdu länder
dringen darauf dass noch einmal die
verordnung das gesetz verändert wird
dass man bestimmte dinge durchsetzen
kann allerdings ist von einem
bundesweiten lockdown momentan zumindest
weiter nicht die rede die
beschlussvorlage ist ja auch an uns
durch gekommen da ist von clubs und
diskotheken die rede die also
möglicherweise geschlossen werden
könnten eine beschlussvorlage der cdu
geführten länder muss man dazu sagen und
die spd geführten länder waren nach
unseren informationen sogar ein bisschen
sauer dass überhaupt so eine
beschlussvorlage
eingebracht wurde denn es sollte ja
keine regulären
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sein
sondern ich glaub olaf scholz hat gesagt
er so eine art kamingespräch genau so
ist es thomas die spd wollte sprechen
telefonieren darüber reden was man
machen könnte die cdu sagt wir müssen
entscheiden es gab es einen
interessanten satz den es dort gerade
gegeben hat unter anderem von herrn
kretschmann der gesagt hat das will ich
einmal vorlesen und zwar hat kretschmann
gesagt dass man heute beschlüsse fassen
müsse er sagt wir sind am höhepunkt der
krise bislang gab es immer vorlagen und
heute gab es nur eine vorlesung vom
künftigen kanzler soll ich mir da alles
mitschreiben und dann kann aktuell
theater schließen aber modelle muss ich
offen lassen ich kann keine gastro
schließen wir brauchen doch jetzt eine
systematik in der krise und das winfried
kretschmann das sagt als
ministerpräsident von baden württemberg
grüner also am ende eigentlich teil der
neuen regierung das hat schon eine
andere qualität dass jetzt ein grüner
ministerpräsident olaf scholz angreifen
wenn es jetzt zu einer abstimmung im
bundestag kommen sollte die frage ist ja
wann würde dass sein und würde ist eine
eigene abstimmung zu einer impfpflicht
werden wäre da sicher dass es eine große
mehrheit
im bundestag dafür geben wird ich gehe
davon aus dass es stand jetzt eine
mehrheit geben würde
die cdu hat sich in weiten teilen in
dieser richtung ausgesprochen bei den
grünen muss man abwarten da gibt es
durchaus auch
impfgegner in den eigenen reihen oder
zumindest welche die diesen druck nicht
ausüben wollen die fdp wäre sicherlich
geteilt ja fd komplett dagegen aber ganz
generell gehe ich davon aus dass es eine
mehrheit für eine impfpflicht dann geben
könnte wir kennen ja eigentlich die
ganze bürokratie in deutschland was
meinst du wie lange würde es dauern bis
wenn man jetzt die impfpflicht
beschließt bis das auch wirklich dann ja
durch die ganzen ämter und so weiter
läuft das ist offen es kommt jetzt ein
bisschen drauf an welche anderen
beschlüsse gefasst werden ja es gibt ja
noch eine mpk an neunten dezember dort
könnte man das sozusagen anschieben aber
noch einmal ist müsste im bundestag
beschlossen werden auch auf druck der
fdp das könnten nicht einfach die
ministerpräsidenten durchsetzen und
sagen die impfpflicht gilt jetzt und
dann kommt die große frage die an
michael müller der berliner regierende
bürgermeister aufgestellt hat die frage
wie kontrolliert man das ja also das ist
ja auch die gleiche frage aber es wird
doch 2g 3g kann ja auch kontrolliert
werden ist doch letztlich das gleiche
nicht so ganz weil sozusagen diese
impfpflicht ja nochmal weiterging denn
da würde man dann auch über bußgelder
irgendwann zum beispiel sprechen jetzt
kann man sagen wann will eine
impfpflicht und sagt man macht einfach
alles zweig aber eine klassische
impfpflicht wie sie zum beispiel in
österreich umgesetzt wird die besteht
dann auch aus bußgeldern irgendwas hatte
ich schon etwas darüber gehört ab wie
viel jahren an sich dann impfen lassen
muss weil man kann ja jetzt kinder ab
fünf jahren schon impfen lassen es gibt
keine details bislang es gibt nur die
aussage von olaf scholz dass er das
möchte es gibt auch keine
gesetzesvorlage da ist alles offen eine
hammer aussage an diesem tag und wenn
man dann gleichzeitig heute rausschaut
ins land und sieht die langen schlangen
beim boostern alleine fragt man sich
wirklich wie das dann so schnell
bewältigt werden soll auf jeden fall
noch mal eine große herausforderung für
den dann neuen gesundheitsminister auch
das ein thema ja heute warum gibt es
denen nicht eigentlich schon warum hat
olaf scholz gerade in diesem ressort das
jetzt so wichtig ist nicht für einen
nahtlosen übergang gesorgt olaf scholz
hat sich dagegen markus söder gestellt
hätte nochmal gefordert hat es müsse
doch jetzt ein gesundheitsminister geben
und was soll dieser krisenstab er soll
den einfach benennen urlaubsorts hat
gesagt er bleibt bei seinem zeitplan am
wochenende spd parteitag dann stellt er
die minister für die ressource ist und
was ja auch ein großes thema heute ist
ist eben der locker und ob es jetzt
einen bundesweiten lockt darum geben
soll markus söder zb hat sich ja auch
eben dafür ausgesprochen viele andere
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidentin eben dagegen warum
port markus söder so auf diesen
bundesweiten locker und was hat er davon
der bayerische ministerpräsident will
nicht der einzige sein oder einer von
wenigen der maßnahmen durchführt er wird
immer sagen es geht dann darum dass dann
die leute aus bayern nicht in andere
bundesländer fahren und da ist dann
sozusagen voll wird und man habe in
wahrheit das problem überall deutschland
vielleicht ein bisschen zeitversetzt
allerdings ist es so dass ist das
natürlich auch ein gewisses politisches
problem für ihn ist wenn er zeigen muss
ich muss dicht machen schleswig holstein
bleibt auch schon interessant die
entwicklung von markus söder der ja
sozusagen eine der gallionsfiguren waren
in diesen ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen an abschluss immer neben der
kanzlerin war der mann der gewarnt hat
auf dem mann gehört hat und doch jetzt
eigentlich so ein bisschen muss man
sagen ab vom schuss und nicht mehr so
richtig in der spur oder sehe ich seit
heute ein bisschen anders denn er hat
die impfpflicht bereits gefordert olaf
scholz zieht nach er hat gefordert dass
es verschärfungen geben muss bereits im
gesetz die spd hat es umgesetzt schauen
wir mal was als nächstes kommt also
nicht auszuschließen dass am ende genau
das umgesetzt wird was söder und
kretschmer seit wochen fordern und er
bleibt seinem motto treu dieses berühmte
team vorsichtig bin der härteste in
allen maßnahmen da hat er sein image an
die nicht veränderten die bevölkerung
ist ja auch dafür in der letzten umfrage
die wir gerade gestern fürbitte
veröffentlicht haben waren ich glaube 58
prozent war die zahl der deutschen der
befragten sind für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht insofern nennt man da
zumindest bei diesem teil 58 prozent
kann man davon ausgehen das sind all die
die schule geimpft sind er rennt man da
natürlich offene türen ein obwohl eine
kleine gute nachricht heute an diesem
tag ihrer du hast uns heute die zahlen
am corona zahlen vorgelesen zum ersten
mal wieder leicht gesunken sind wobei
man sagen muss also ich finde natürlich
die mehrheit der bevölkerung ist für die
impfpflicht von daher kann man sagen
möglicherweise richtig aus dieser
perspektive dass sich der kanzlerin
anschließend nur mir macht sorgen was
ist mit dem rest der bevölkerung wir
erleben jetzt schon eine spaltung in
vielen politischen themen gerade bei
kommen das ist da auch wieder zu
krawallen kommen will ob es zu krawallen
kommt weiß ich nicht aber definitiv
werden diejenigen sich in ihrer meinung
dass die politik ihnen etwas vor gelogen
hat als sie gesagt haben die impfpflicht
wird nicht kommen wir erinnern uns da ja
daran dass es diese demonstration
gegeben hat und dass die querdenker
gesagt haben die politik jetzt sagen sie
die impfpflicht wird es nicht geben und
plötzlich kommt sie also sozusagen die
schlimmsten vorwürfe für alle
verschwörungstheoretiker könnten dann
wahr werden und das bedeutet ja am ende
eine weitere radikalisierung dieses
teils der gesellschaft die sich eben
nicht impfen lassen wollen und die frage
ist kann man mit einer pflicht wirklich
diejenigen erreichen die sich bis jetzt
nicht impfen lassen wollen wäre es nicht
besser zu sagen wir machen das
freiwillig weiterhin gegeben anreize
oder wir sagen wir machen zweig was ja
auch schon eine art pflicht nachkommt
aber nichts dann mit bußgeldern oder
ähnlichem zu tun das heißt wäre und
hätte wir können glaube ich sagen nach
dieser entscheidung von olaf scholz dass
er persönlich für eine impfpflicht dem
bundestag stimmen würde ist dieser zug
in diese richtung abgefahren